a series of tweets you know sort of a a
a tweet thread of 15 tweets that
assesses the quality of the evidence for
masks pros and cons and and sort of
where this that's not going to go viral
you know
um but you know a Smackdown for
a famous politician who is famously in
favor of masks who also went to a dinner
and didn't wear a mask that's going to
go viral and you know that that's partly
human nature
um you know people love to call out
hypocrisy and all that but it's partly
what these systems Elevate automatically
I talk about this with respect to
Facebook for example so I think Facebook
has done a pretty good job
although it's taken longer than it
should in some cases but you know if you
have a
a very large following and you're really
spouting hatred or or misinformation
disinformation they've kicked people off
they've done you know some reasonable
things there
but actually the deeper issue is
um of this this um the anger we're
talking about of the the contentiousness
of everything
I make of a family example
um with two great stereotypes um so one
the the the crackpot Racist uncle and
one the sweet grandma
and I always want to point out my all of
my uncles and my family were wonderful
people so I didn't have a crackpot racer
but everybody knows the stereotype yes
well so Grandma she just posts like
sweet comments on the kids pictures and
congratulates people on their wedding
anniversary and crackpot uncles posting
his nonsense
and normally uh sort of at Christmas
dinner everybody rolls their eyes oh
yeah uncle Frank's here and he's
probably gonna say some racist comment
and we're gonna tell him to shut up or
you know maybe let's not inviting this
year the normal human drama
he's got his three mates down at the pub
who listen to him and and all of that
but now
Grandma's got you know 54 followers on
Facebook which is the intimate family
and Racist uncle has 714. so he's not a
massive influence or whatever but how
did that happen it's because the
algorithm notices oh when when she posed
nothing happens he posts and then
everybody jumps in to go gosh shut up
Uncle Frank you know like that's
outrageous
and it's like oh there's engagement
there's page views there's ads right and
and those algorithms I think they're
working to improve that but it's really
hard for them it's hard to improve that
if that actually is working if the
people who are saying things that get
engagement
um if it's not too awful but it's just
you know like maybe it's not a racist
cycle but maybe it's an uncle who posts
a lot about what an idiot Biden is Right
which isn't necessarily an offensive or
blockable or bannable thing and it
shouldn't be
but if that's the discourse that gets
elevated because it gets a rise out of
people then suddenly in a society it's
like oh this is we get more of what we
reward so I I think that's a piece of
what's gone on well if we could just uh
take that tangent I'm having a
conversation with Mark Zuckerberg a
second time is there something you can
comment on how to decrease toxicity on
that particular platform Facebook you
also have worked on creating a social
network that is less toxic yourself yeah
so can we just talk about the different
ideas that these already big social
network can do and what you have been
trying to do so a piece of it is
um
it's hard so I don't the problem with
making a recommendation to Facebook is
that I actually believe their business
model makes it really hard for them uh
and I'm not anti-capitalism I'm not you
know great somebody's got business
they're making money that's not that's
not where I come from
but certain business models mean you are
going to prioritize
things that maybe aren't that long-term
healthful and so that's a big piece of
it so certainly for Facebook you could
say you know uh with vast resources
start to prioritize content that's
higher quality that's healing that's
kind
uh try not to prioritize content that
seems to be just getting a rise out of
people now those are vague human
descriptions right but I do believe good
machine learning algorithms you can
optimize in slightly different ways but
to do that you may have to say actually
we're not necessarily going to increase
page views to the maximum extent right
now and I've said this to people at at
Facebook it's like
you know it if if your actions are you
know convincing people that you're
breaking Western Civilization that's
really bad for business in the long run
um certainly these days I'll say Twitter
is the thing that's on people's minds as
being more upsetting at the moment
but I think it's true
um and so
one of the things that's really
interesting about Facebook compared to a
lot of companies is that Mark has a
pretty unprecedented amount of power
his ability to name members of the board
to his control of the company is is
pretty hard to break
even if
Financial results aren't as good as they
could be because he's taken a step back
from
the perfect optimization to say actually
for the long-term Health in the next 50
years of this organization we need to
rein in some of the things that are
working for us and making money because
they're actually giving us a bad
reputation so one of the recommendations
I would say is and this is not to do
with the algorithms and all that but you
know how about just a moratorium on all
political advertising I don't think it's
their most profitable segment but it's
given rise to a lot of deep hard
questions about dark money about
um you know ads that are run by
questionable people that push false
narratives or you know the classic kind
of thing is you run uh I saw a study
about brexit in in the UK where people
were talking about there were ads run
um
to
uh animal rights activists saying
finally when we're out from under Europe
the UK can pass proper animal rights
legislation we're not constrained by the
European process
similarly for people who are Advocates
of fox hunting to say finally when we're
out of Europe we can we can re-implement
so you're telling people what they want
to hear and
in some cases it's really hard for
journalists to see that so it used to be
that for political advertising you
really needed to find some kind of
mainstream narrative and this is still
true to an extent mainstream narrative
that
60 of people can say oh I can buy into
that which meant it pushed you to the
center it pushed you to sort of try and
find some nuanced balance
but if your main method of recruiting
people is an a tiny little one-on-one
conversation with them because you're
able to Target using targeted
advertising suddenly you don't need uh
consistent you just need a really good
uh targeting uh operation really good
Cambridge analytic style machine
learning algorithm data to convince
people and that just feels really
problematic so I mean until they can
think about how to solve that problem I
just say you know what it's going to
cost us x amount but it's going to be
worth it to kind of say you know what we
actually think our political advertising
policy hasn't really helped uh
contribute to dot discourse and dialogue
and finding reasoned you know middle
ground and compromised solution so let's
just not do that for a while until we
figure that out so that's maybe a piece
of advice and and coupled with as you
were saying recommender systems for the
news feed and other contexts
that don't always optimize engagement
but optimize the long-term mental
well-being and balance and growth of a
human being yeah but it's very difficult
problem it's a difficult problem yeah
and you know so in in with uh WT social
Wiki screen social we're launching in a
few months time a completely new system
new domain name new lots of things but
the idea is to say let's let's focus on
trust
people can rate each other as
trustworthy rate content is trustworthy
you have to start from somewhere so
start with a core base of our tiny
Community who I think are sensible
thoughtful people we want to recruit
more but to say you know what actually
let's have that as a pretty strong
element to say let's not optimize based
on what gets the most page views in this
session let's optimize on what sort of
the feedback from people is this is
meaningfully enhancing my life and so
part of that is and it's probably not a
good business model but part of that is
okay we're not going to pursue an
advertising business model but
a you know membership model where you
know you can you don't have to be a
member but you can pay to be a member uh
you maybe get some benefit from that but
in general
to say actually the problem with and
actually the The Division I would say is
and the analogy I would give is
broadcast television funded by
advertising
gives you a different result than
paying for HBO paying for Netflix paying
for whatever and the reason is
you know if you think about it if what
what is your incentive as uh
a TV producer you're going to make a
comedy for
ABC Network in the US you basically say
I want something that almost everybody
will like and listen to so it tends to
be a little blander you know family
friendly whatever whereas if you say oh
actually I'm going to use the HBO
example and an old example you say you
know what Sopranos isn't for everybody
Sex in the City isn't for everybody but
between the two shows we've got
something for everybody that they're
willing to pay for so you can get edgier
higher quality in my view content rather
than saying it's Gotta not offend
anybody in the world it's got to be for
everybody which is really hard so same
thing you know here in a social network
if your business model is advertising
it's going to drive you in One Direction
if your business model is membership I
think it drives you in a different
direction I actually and I said this to
Elon
um about Twitter blue which I think
wasn't rolled out well and so forth but
it's like the piece of that that I like
is to say look actually if there's a
model where your revenue is coming from
people who are willing to pay for the
service even if it's only part of your
Revenue if it's a substantial part that
does change your broader incentives to
say actually are people going to be
willing to pay for something that's
actually just toxicity in their lives
um now I'm not sure it's been rolled out
well I'm not sure how it's going and
maybe I'm wrong about that as a
plausible business model uh but I do
think it's interesting to think about
just in in Broad terms
business model drives outcomes in
sometimes surprising ways unless you
really pause to think about it